the version of donald trump that i
call downer trump showed up yesterday in
the rose garden
to sign an executive order about police
departments
directing police departments to stop
using choke holds
and donald trump did look very very
unwell
and he said things that made no sense
whatsoever so this again raised
questions about whether donald trump is
suffering the side effects of some
illness
side effects of medication cognitive
decline something else that we can't
seem to put a finger on
we discussed yesterday on the bonus show
extensively the question of police using
chokeholds
and the reality that the priority should
be rather than a list of tactics that
police can and can't use the focus
should be on training officers to
de-escalate situations so that choke
holds
aren't even in the picture but we talked
about that yesterday
right now i want to focus on the
absolute implosion of donald trump
during this rose garden statement
here is donald trump saying that we have
developed a vaccine for aids
now that's not true we have not
developed a vaccine for aids and trump
when he says it
gets that look on his face where he
seems to
understand that he said something wrong
but
he almost is lost and doesn't know what
he said it was like that time where he
did the oranges of the investigation
thing
and he kind of tries to back it up and
mumbles a few things take a look at this
they have come up with things and
they've come up with
many other cures and therapeutics over
the years these are the people the best
the smartest the most brilliant anywhere
and they've come up with the aids
vaccine
they've come up with or the aids and as
you know there's various things and now
various companies are
involved but the therapeutic for aids
aids was a death sentence and now people
live a life with a pill
it's an incredible thing the ebola vic
so that same confusion happened when
trump
repeatedly said he wanted to find out
the oranges
the citrus fruit of an investigation he
said it twice and he had a look where
he knew he was saying something that
didn't make sense but he almost couldn't
even parse it in his own mind
it didn't get any better during the same
event donald trump seemed to lose his
train of thought this is another pattern
we've seen where he forgets what he's
talking about he will just look at
someone and say
right you know what i'm talking about
don't you we've seen this before
this time he looks into the audience and
he says right tim
we're going to pursue things very
strongly you can tell if you're watching
that trump doesn't seem lucid when you
look at his face
right when this is happening take a look
and i gave a commitment to all of those
families today with
senator tim scott attorney general bill
barr
we are going to pursue
what we said we will be pursuing it and
we will be pursuing it strongly tim
right okay
wacky stuff uh at another moment donald
trump was talking about
putting down the protesters by using the
national guard
and of course putting down is certainly
not
the most humane language to use trump
bragging about how strongly the
protesters were handled
and your federal government is ready
willing and able
to help as we did in
minneapolis after we got out of control
for four days
we sent in representatives commonly
known as the national guard and it was
all
put down very quickly we're willing to
help we're willing to help in seattle
we're willing to help anywhere you want
so
when there are protests against police
brutality
and your response is to brag about how
much force
you directed be used against the
protesters
something is not quite getting through
then donald trump absolutely bizarrely
interjecting a complete non-sequitur
about school choice being the civil
rights issue of our time take a look at
this
we're fighting for school choice which
really is the civil rights
of all time in this country frankly
school choice is the civil rights
statement of the year so understand that
when republicans talk about school
choice what they really mean is
defund public schools weaken public
schools often with voucher programs
which go to charter schools which then
continues the vicious cycle of
worsening public schools because you've
just pulled money from them this is a
favorite of republicans
say public education is bad of course
it's underfunded
use that to justify taking more money
out of public education
which makes it worse so that then they
can again justify look at how bad public
education is
we've got to do more charter schools and
private schools it's an
old trope from republicans and then
lastly here another one of these moments
where donald trump
lists different races and ethnicities
and
incorrectly claims that almost everybody
had a high paying job before the
coronavirus hit
that's for almost every group including
black
hispanic asian women
young people old people
young people without a high school
diploma
every group everybody was thrilled
everybody had
just about high-paying jobs
our country was never in a better
position and we were planning on massive
growth it was happening it was already
there
so one of the things we've seen in terms
of job creation
before coronavirus hit was that while
the jobs numbers were good and i have no
problem admitting that
a lot of the jobs being created were
what we call
bs jobs not medium or high-wage jobs but
low-wage jobs or sometimes jobs that
aren't even really jobs they're
contractor positions
and this is a common deception that we
are hearing from the right
so there it is a combination of donald
trump looking
and sounding confused making verifiably
false claims
and the mood in the audience a
combination of
quiet confusion horror but also blind
loyalty the people that see this and at
least
tell themselves that everything is
completely fine so we're going to be
following up on this
on our instagram page if you're not
following the show on instagram
please do at david pakman show and
in fact this is getting so bad that
it has gone on to fox news fox news
talking about the trump health situation
a republican group now targeting trump
around
health concerns so this is important
that it is broken past
just certain areas and even elements of
the right
are now talking about trump's health and
being put in a position
to have to defend it we'll get to that
after the interview today